l'album de la mode 79 nous tournons une
troisième page avec france roche après
l'extravagance et la sagesse voici la
décontraction la mode dont vous serez
paré madame lorsque nous rencontrerons
au détour d'un stade à la campagne ou
dans de lointains espace style norvégien
de perse book tricot jacquard et bottes
aussi peu creed que la bonne car elles
ont un talon intérieur de 5 cm dessous
la roma trois auteurs visible
et
toujours norvégien et de spock
l'ensemble avec basque écharpe broderie
écoles ou
pour les voyages plus démocratique un
manteau de pâtes ou un manteau
d'orpheline à héritage avec pas noir
béret petite cravate d'institutrice bien
payé
pour affronter les neiges des caps
capuche et capuchon
celle de carven avec toc superposés sur
la cagoule
celle de courrèges pantalon droit d'eau
douillet celle de lapidus en velours
côtelé de l'ain un tissu nouveau
pour se promener dans la campagne sans
nécessairement chasser le lapin ou
l'agro un petit terre des causses
proposé par torrent avec cap écharpe
tartan et béret de clan
un peu moins écossais avec ses bas noirs
cette veste de cuir mais toujours le
béret
et juste un petit souvenir d'edimbourg
pour la roche avec cette écharpe d'azur
enfin pour rouler dans la campagne je ne
dis pas pour faire de l'auto-stop
ou alors peut-être dans ce cas là
l'ensemble de balmain ou manteaux droits
et combinaisons peut-être sans doute
comme dans le cas de dépannage mais on a
quand même intérêt à appeler un
garagiste